Selamat kembali ke Quantum Computing dalam Praktik. Ini episod 6. Hari ini kita akan fokus pada salah satu aplikasi kegemaran saya
bagi komputer quantum, mensimulasikan alam semulajadi. Dalam episod ini, kita akan bincangkan langkah-langkah yang diperlukan
untuk melakukan ini bagi sebarang jenis masalah dinamik quantum, iaitu masalah mencari bagaimana huraian
sistem quantum berubah mengikut masa. Kita akan buat ini pada peringkat tinggi dahulu kemudian lihat contoh tertentu dan lalui
dengan terperinci. iaitu eksperimen IBM 2023 yang menunjukkan utiliti quantum. Untuk sedikit motivasi awal,
salah satu kisah paling terkenal yang mereka dalam bidang quantum computing cerita berulang kali,
kisah Richard Feynman memberi kuliah di Caltech pada tahun 1959 dan pada asasnya
menyediakan motivasi untuk keseluruhan bidang selama dekad-dekad. Ucapan itu dipanggil there's plenty of room at the
bottom. tajuk yang lucu, tapi idea asasnya adalah dia mendakwa masih ada banyak fizik yang kaya untuk ditemui
pada peringkat mikroskopik.
Sekarang, ucapan tertentu tu tidak mendapat banyak perhatian sehingga tahun 80-an apabila teknologi dah berkembang cukup. Dan Feynman
juga menjelaskan dan memperhalusi mesejnya dari masa ke masa. Dia kembali ke Caltech pada tahun 80-an dan membentangkan kertas lain yang dipanggil
simulating nature with computers di mana dia secara khusus berkata dia nak bercakap tentang kemungkinan bahawa ada
simulasi yang tepat bahawa komputer akan buat tepat sama seperti alam semulajadi.
pada asasnya dapat menyingkirkan anggaran kasar tentang apa yang berlaku pada skala atom dan menggantikannya dengan
komputer yang memahami dan memanfaatkan fizik quantum untuk tidak hanya mensimulasikan apa yang alam semulajadi buat, tetapi menirunya.
Sekarang, ingat grafik garis masa ini yang saya tunjukkan dalam episod sebelumnya. Di satu hujung, kita ada masalah yang mudah untuk
diselesaikan dan tidak akan memerlukan sebarang jenis pecutan quantum yang boleh ditawarkan. Tapi di hujung lain, kita ada masalah yang
sangat susah dan memerlukan mesin quantum toleran ralat yang kita belum miliki lagi.
Nasib baik, kita percaya ada cukup banyak masalah simulasi yang terletak di sini di tengah, iaitu kawasan yang
kita boleh bekerjakan sekarang. Dan ada banyak sebab untuk teruja dan tertarik dengan prospek ini kerana
simulasi alam semulajadi adalah asas kepada banyak kawasan aplikasi yang menarik. hanya untuk sebut beberapa. Kalau kita boleh lebih baik
mensimulasikan alam semulajadi, kita boleh mempercepatkan penemuan bahan baru, cipta farmaseutikal dan ubat yang lebih baik, atau
bahkan terokai fizik baru yang mendasari fizik zarah atau kosmologi. Tapi sebelum korang atau saya atau sesiapa pun boleh cuba untuk
menerapkan quantum computing kepada kawasan yang menarik ni buat masa ini, mereka perlu faham langkah-langkah asas dalam aliran kerja
berasaskan simulasi biasa.
Pertama, korang nak kenal pasti sistem quantum yang diminati. Ini akan memaklumkan korang tentang Hamiltonian yang mengawal evolusi masanya
dan huraian bermakna tentang sifat permulaannya atau keadaannya.
Kemudian korang perlu cari kaedah yang sesuai untuk melaksanakan evolusi masa keadaan ini. Dengan bahan-bahan ini
diselesaikan, langkah seterusnya melibatkan menjalankan eksperimen sebenar.
Ini umumnya melibatkan mengoptimumkan pelaksanaan quantum circuit algoritma evolusi masa, melaksanakan
circuit atau circuit pada perkakasan quantum dan pasca-memproses hasilnya. Jadi kita
boleh namakan langkah-langkah asas yang terlibat dalam eksperimen simulasi seperti berikut.
Mengenal pasti Hamiltonian sistem, pengekodan Hamiltonian, penyediaan keadaan, evolusi keadaan,
pengoptimuman circuit, pelaksanaan circuit, dan pasca-pemprosesan.
Tapi ini adalah langkah-langkah yang agak terperinci. Ingat empat peringkat rangka kerja Qiskit patterns, yang membantu
kita faham cara melaksanakan rutin dalam Qiskit adalah pemetaan, pengoptimuman circuit, pelaksanaan circuit, dan
pasca-pemprosesan. Jadi empat langkah pertama di sini sebenarnya semua termasuk dalam pemetaan dan itulah
sebabnya kita habiskan satu episod penuh pada peringkat pertama ini dan kalau korang terlepas sila pergi balik dan tonton episod sebelumnya.
Sekarang jom lalui dahulu apa yang langkah-langkah ini bermaksud sebelum kita terjun ke mana-mana pengekodan. Jadi perkara asas pertama yang kita perlu
buat untuk menjalankan eksperimen simulasi adalah mengenal pasti Hamiltonian yang menerangkan sistem. Kadang-kadang
selalunya ini diketahui ramai kali lain kita perlu menyatukannya daripada memahami sumbangan tenaga
subset kecil sistem penuh seperti ini di mana hi adalah Hamiltonian yang bertindak pada salah satu daripada n subsistem h.
Kita juga perlu ambil perhatian sama ada sistem terdiri daripada fermion atau boson kalau kita berurusan dengan zarah dasar. Seterusnya,
kita perlu mengekod Hamiltonian dan menterjemahkannya kepada sebutan yang komputer quantum boleh faham. Selalunya,
Hamiltonian ini akan terdiri daripada zarah dasar atau sistem spin. Kalau kita mensimulasikan fermion atau boson, kita
perlu memilih transformasi pengekodan seperti Jordan-Wigner atau Bravyi-Kitaev. Transformasi ini akan
memberitahu kita cara menterjemahkan definisi Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam sebutan komponen asal. fermion atau
boson kepada operator Pauli yang mudah ditukarkan kepada gates pada komputer quantum. Contohnya, transformasi Jordan-Wigner
yang ditakrifkan di sini memberi pemetaan dari operator fermionik kepada operator Pauli. Kalau kita sudah berurusan
dengan sistem spin 1/2 yang sangat biasa maka kita bagus untuk mulakan selain daripada sebarang kemungkinan pekali normalisasi
dan kita tidak perlu guna skim pengekodan. Setelah mengekod Hamiltonian yang dikehendaki ke dalam set gate
komputer quantum, langkah penting seterusnya adalah menentukan keadaan quantum awal yang sesuai untuk memulakan simulasi
kita. Keadaan ini seharusnya mencerminkan beberapa makna fizikal atau konfigurasi
sistem yang dikaji. Contohnya, kalau kita berminat meneroka tenaga keadaan asas molekul, kita mungkin
mulakan dengan anggaran Hartree-Fock atau ansatz lain yang mudah disediakan yang mempunyai tindihan yang signifikan dengan keadaan asas sebenar
keadaan asas. Pilihan keadaan asas awal mempengaruhi bukan sahaja penumpuan algoritma variasi
seperti VQE penyelesai quantum variasi tetapi juga ketepatan dan kecekapan
evolusi masa atau pensampelan dalam anggaran fasa quantum. Pada intinya, keadaan awal berfungsi sebagai
titik permulaan untuk pengiraan yang menetapkan persada untuk mengekstrak pemerhati berguna tentang sistem quantum
yang kita modelkan. penyediaan keadaan n qubit sewenang-wenangnya di mana ci adalah keadaan asas pengiraan dan ai adalah
WEBVTT
pekali masing-masing setiap keadaan dan syarat normalisasi 2 n tolak satu secara umumnya boleh didekati dengan
memulakan keadaan dengan operator o keadaan permulaan akan menjadi keadaan asas semua sifar yang sering ditulis
seperti ini untuk penyederhanaan secara umumnya ini memerlukan bilangan gate C NOT yang eksponen banyak kali kita
berminat dengan keadaan awal tertentu untuk sistem dan penyediaannya boleh dilaksanakan dengan jumlah sumber yang munasabah
Keadaan hasil darab contohnya di mana qubit tidak terjait antara satu sama lain hanya memerlukan operasi qubit tunggal
Sekarang kita sebenarnya belum ada peluang untuk bercakap tentang trotterisasi
walaupun beberapa daripada korang mungkin dah biasa dengannya. Pada intinya, trotterisasi adalah kaedah untuk mengira eksponen matriks yang
menggunakan anggaran untuk mengendalikan sifat eksponen operator yang tidak bertukar ganti. Bila dua operator seperti HA
dan HB tidak bertukar ganti, maka kita perlu gunakan trik yang bijak dan gantikan secara alternatif eksponen yang sepadan dengan
e kepada i ha dan e kepada i hb untuk n bilangan
kali. operator evolusi yang berselang-seli diterapkan. Saya tak akan pergi melalui bukti di sini, tapi saya akan berkongsi pautan
kepada bukti yang mudah dan baik tentang penyataan ini dalam deskripsi. Tapi mesej utama adalah ini. Evolusi masa adalah
bahagian penting pemetaan juga. Trotterisasi memecahkan interaksi berterusan kepada langkah-langkah diskret yang boleh
dilaksanakan pada komputer quantum. Selepas menghasilkan circuit yang ditrotterisasi, kita akhirnya selesai dengan
langkah pemetaan. Kita kini boleh beralih kepada pengoptimuman circuit.
Untuk buat itu, ini yang perlu dicapai. Perlu ada susun atur qubit yang memetakan qubit maya
circuit korang kepada yang fizikal pada perkakasan. Ini diperlukan kerana perkakasan boleh mempunyai topologi tertentu
yang menyekat interaksi langsung qubit fizikal. Manakala pelaksanaan
quantum circuit sering mengandaikan keupayaan mana-mana qubit untuk berinteraksi dengan mana-mana qubit lain. Kemudian kita perlu masukkan
swap gates mengikut keperluan untuk laluan interaksi antara qubit yang tidak disambungkan. Kita perlu terjemahkan
gates dalam circuit kita kepada seni bina set arahan atau arahan ISA yang
boleh dilaksanakan terus pada perkakasan. Kemudian kita perlu lakukan pengoptimuman circuit untuk meminimumkan
kedalaman circuit dan bilangan gate. Langkah ini juga boleh dilakukan pada circuit maya. Circuit di mana qubit
belum lagi dipetakan ke topologi peranti. Tapi ingat banyak daripada ini dilakukan secara automatik untuk korang dalam
Qiskit. Kita akan tengok tepat bagaimana dalam bahagian kuliah seterusnya. Selepas langkah pengoptimuman, kita sedia untuk jalankan
circuit menggunakan primitive. Untuk kebanyakan eksperimen simulasi, korang berminat untuk faham perubahan
sifat-sifat tertentu sistem dengan masa. Jadi korang mungkin akan menggunakan estimator primitive sebab itu
akan membolehkan korang mengukur nilai jangkaan pemerhati yang sepadan dengan sifat-sifat tertentu. Kemudian kita akan
konfigurasikan pilihan terbaik untuk estimator yang boleh menambah teknik penekanan ralat dan mitigasi ralat. Akhirnya, kita akan jalankan
eksperimen. Langkah terakhir adalah pasca-memproses semua data. Ini mengekstrak nilai jangkaan yang diukur atau kalau
korang menggunakan sampler, taburan kebarangkalian sampel dalam asas pengiraan. Kalau semua yang diperlukan
hanyalah nilai jangkaan pemerhati yang diminati, ini boleh diperoleh terus daripada estimator
primitive dalam nilai mentah dan nilai yang dikurangkan ralat. Selalunya seseorang kemudian akan menggunakan nilai jangkaan yang diukur
untuk pengiraan lain bagi kuantiti lain yang diminati yang tidak memerlukan pengiraan quantum dan boleh
dikira pada komputer klasikal.
Sekarang kita akan lalui contoh sebenar daripada kertas yang sangat berpengaruh yang IBM terbitkan beberapa tahun lalu yang dipanggil
the evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance. Sekarang kertas ini yang kita singkatkan dengan mesra sebagai
kertas utiliti menjadi kertas yang sangat berpengaruh dalam bidang quantum computing hampir serta-merta setelah diterbitkan.
Tesis keseluruhan kertas ni adalah bahawa komputer quantum berbunyi menghasilkan hasil yang tepat atau nilai jangkaan
menggunakan 127 qubit dan 2,880 gate di luar keupayaan pengiraan brute force
iaitu simulasi tepat circuit quantum yang dilaksanakan oleh perkakasan. Kerja ini juga
penting kerana ia menunjukkan bahawa komputer quantum boleh digunakan untuk mengesahkan atau membandingkan hasil dengan kaedah
klasikal anggaran lain untuk simulasi quantum seperti algoritma tensor network di mana penyelesaian
tidak diketahui a priori. Yang juga agak keren adalah kini orang lain menggunakan sistem IBM quantum pada
cloud dan Qiskit boleh duplikasikan dan sahkan hasil ini sendiri.
Saya akan tunjukkan korang cara buat itu. Jadi untuk contoh ini, kita akan lebih spesifik tentang
langkah-langkah yang terlibat dalam memetakan masalah ini kepada input yang boleh difahami oleh peranti quantum. Dalam kes ini, kita akan
mensimulasikan dinamik jumlah magnetisasi sistem spin dwikutub magnetik pada kekisi dalam
kehadiran medan magnet luaran. Sistem boleh diterangkan oleh model Ising dengan medan magnet melintang.
Kita modelkan ini dengan quantum circuit berparameter di mana parameter sepadan dengan nilai yang boleh ditala
interaksi spin-spin atau z dan kekuatan medan magnet X. Sekarang,
siri ini dipanggil quantum computing dalam praktik. Jadi, kita juga akan bincangkan prosedur dalam eksperimen ini
yang kita akan laksanakan untuk menjadikan hasil sebaik mungkin. Jadi seterusnya kita akan bincangkan cara mengeluarkan
qubit buruk atau qubit dengan kesetiaan gate yang rendah atau masa dekoherensi yang boleh memberi kesan mendalam kepada
hasil eksperimen. Qubit buruk ini boleh berlaku akibat penentukuran semasa yang lemah
atau sistem dua aras yang berinteraksi dengan qubit. Mengeluarkan beberapa qubit dari topologi natif perkakasan sepadan dengan
mempertimbangkan sistem pada kekisi yang diterangkan oleh topologi yang terhasil. Kita juga akan bincangkan cara mencipta
quantum circuit berparameter yang melaksanakan evolusi masa sistem melalui trotterisasi.
Untuk tujuan ini, akan penting untuk mengenal pasti lapisan yang menjalin yang merupakan bahagian penting untuk teknik mitigasi ralat utama
yang akan kita gunakan kemudian. Jadi pada ketika ini saya nak pastikan korang penonton tahu
bahawa korang boleh ikuti semua yang saya nak bincangkan dalam tutorial yang dipautkan di bawah dan pada platform pembelajaran IBM
WEBVTT
quantum. Dalam tutorial ini, apa yang mungkin korang perasan adalah kita telah mencipta siri fungsi pembantu
awal dalam notebook yang boleh kita panggil kemudian untuk memudahkan kehidupan kita sedikit. Saya nak sebut ini
sekarang, bukan kerana ia adalah sebahagian daripada proses rasmi atau formal, tetapi kerana ini sering apa yang dilakukan eksperimentalis
dalam kehidupan sebenar untuk membantu mereka menjalankan jenis eksperimen ini. Dan ia juga menunjukkan kepada kita cara kita akan memecahkan
masalah kita dengan lebih lanjut. Fungsi yang kita takrifkan dalam notebook adalah seperti berikut. Keluarkan gandingan qubit.
Takrifkan gandingan qubit. Bina gandingan lapisan. Bina lapisan yang menjalin. Dan akhirnya, takrifkan
circuit yang ditrotterisasi. Seterusnya, jom bercakap tentang gandingan lapisan, yang membantu mentakrifkan cara qubit
berinteraksi dengan jirannya semasa simulasi. Peranti quantum kita menggunakan sesuatu yang dipanggil susun atur
heksagonal berat. Corak khas untuk menyambungkan qubit. Dalam susun atur ini, kita boleh kumpulkan sambungan yang dipanggil tepi kepada tiga
set berasingan di mana tiada dua sambungan dalam set yang sama berkongsi qubit. Ini
penting kerana pada komputer quantum sebenar, kita tidak boleh jalankan gate qubit dua pada masa yang sama kalau ia melibatkan
qubit yang sama. Setiap qubit hanya boleh terlibat dalam satu gate pada satu masa. Dengan
membahagikan semua sambungan kepada tiga lapisan, kita boleh terapkan gate qubit dua merentasi keseluruhan peranti dalam tiga
pusingan, memastikan tiada qubit digunakan dalam lebih dari satu gate setiap lapisan. Gate-gate
ini melaksanakan interaksi ZZ daripada model Ising, dan diulang pada setiap langkah simulasi yang dipanggil langkah
Trotter. Twirling mengubahsuai bunyi hingar dalam peranti supaya bahkan model bunyi hingar yang mudah
berkemungkinan tepat. Ini juga memungkinkan untuk mempelajari model bunyi hingar dengan tepat dan menggunakan maklumat yang diperoleh
dan teknik mitigasi ralat.
Seterusnya, kita perlu mengeluarkan qubit buruk kita daripada senarai qubit fizikal yang mungkin yang boleh kita gunakan untuk
eksperimen. Macam yang saya katakan, qubit boleh menjadi buruk kerana pelbagai sebab yang berbeza. Kadang-kadang ia hanyalah penentukuran yang buruk,
kesilapan mudah yang boleh diselesaikan dengan hanya menentukur semula.
Kadang-kadang ia agak lebih rumit dan berkaitan dengan sesuatu yang kita panggil TLS, iaitu cacat antara muka dua aras
yang membawa kepada turun naik parameter qubit dan kelonggaran. Ini boleh
diselesaikan dengan memanaskan keseluruhan sistem sedikit dan kemudian menyejukkannya semula. Tapi itu mengambil masa dan tidak boleh dilakukan
melalui cloud. Jadi buat masa ini, perkara paling mudah untuk dilakukan adalah hanya mengecualikan mereka daripada senarai qubit fizikal yang mungkin
yang akan kita gunakan. Korang boleh kenal pasti qubit yang tidak berkelakuan seperti yang dijangkakan dengan mudah dari platform IBM quantum.
Korang boleh plot ciri qubit di sana dalam platform atau muat turunnya sebagai CSV. Kemudian buat senarai semua
qubit yang korang nak kecualikan dan hanya keluarkan mereka daripada senarai jumlah qubit fizikal pada peranti.
Baiklah. Sekarang jom teruskan dengan langkah pemetaan kita menjana circuit yang ditrotterisasi. Sekarang macam yang kita tunjukkan
tadi trotterisasi mendisretkan evolusi masa kepada siri langkah dan kita perlu tentukan berapa banyak langkah.
Kita akan pilih enam di sini. Tapi secara umumnya strategi adalah untuk mengimbangi sesuatu yang dipanggil ralat Trotter iaitu ralat
anggaran algoritma dengan ralat yang timbul daripada dekoherensi. Lebih banyak langkah Trotter mengurangkan ralat anggaran
tapi memerlukan circuit quantum yang lebih dalam yang mengalami lebih banyak bunyi hingar dekoherensi. Kita akan takrifkan
circuit dalam sebutan parameter theta iaitu kekuatan medan magnet luaran gandingan lapisan dan
bilangan langkah dan qubit dan tentunya backend peranti. Kerana
kebergantungan magnetisasi sistem pada kekuatan medan magnet luaran, adalah menarik untuk
laksanakan simulasi pada pelbagai nilai kekuatan medan magnet yang diterjemahkan kepada sudut RX yang berbeza pada
putaran untuk RX dalam circuit. Sekarang setelah menjana circuit kita, kita akan beralih kepada pengoptimumannya.
Langkah pertama di sini adalah untuk takrifkan pengurus laluan. Ingat dalam konteks Qiskit SDK, transpilation merujuk kepada
proses mengubahkan circuit input kepada bentuk yang sesuai untuk pelaksanaan pada peranti quantum.
Transpilation biasanya berlaku dalam urutan langkah yang dipanggil laluan transpiler. Pengurus laluan adalah objek yang
menyimpan senarai laluan transpiler dan boleh melaksanakannya pada circuit. cipta pengurus laluan dengan memulakan objek pengurus laluan
dengan senarai laluan transpiler. Pada akhirnya, pengurus laluan kita
akan mencipta circuit ISA, circuit yang mesti ditulis dalam sebutan seni bina set arahan backend,
yang menerangkan circuit dan gates yang natif kepada backend tetapi kekurangan maklumat masa yang diperlukan untuk menjalankan
circuit. Sekarang kita sedia untuk melaksanakan circuit kita iaitu langkah tiga Qiskit patterns. Sekarang macam yang dinyatakan sebelumnya kita akan
pasti menggunakan estimator di sini sebagai primitive pilihan kita untuk eksperimen ini memandangkan kita nak mengukur
jumlah magnetisasi sistem dan menganggarkan nilai jangkaan pemerhati adalah apa yang estimator
direka untuk. Dalam langkah ini juga akan penting untuk menentukan pilihan kita untuk mitigasi ralat. Kita akan gunakan zero noise
extrapolation untuk mendapatkan hasil yang terbaik yang mungkin. Khususnya dalam tutorial, korang akan lihat bahawa kita tentukan dua atau lebih
nilai faktor bunyi hingar untuk menilai model yang diekstrapolasi dan menentukan
probabilistic error amplification sebagai pilihan amplifikasi kita. Sekarang, probabilistic
error amplification atau PEA memang adalah kaedah teknik mitigasi ralat yang dipilih di sini kerana ia berskala jauh
lebih baik berbanding pilihan lain. Dan itulah yang penting bila kita bekerja pada peringkat 100 qubit ke atas.
Akhir sekali tapi paling penting, jalankan eksperimen dan ia akan mengambil masa untuk selesai, tapi buat masa ini, jom rujuk data
yang tersimpan dalam antrian dari tutorial. Kita akan periksa metadata dengan memberi perhatian khusus kepada gate berlapis dan
lapisan yang dikurangkan memandangkan kita nak menggunakan tu untuk mengeluarkan sekumpulan ralat daripada data mentah kita. Kita hampir sedia
untuk plot keputusan akhir kita. Tapi sebelum kita buat tu, jom tambah selingan di sini tentang apa sebenarnya yang dimaksudkan dengan zero
noise extrapolation atau ZNE. Kita dah bincangkannya secara ringkas dalam episod sebelumnya, tapi untuk ulasan, zero noise extrapolation
adalah teknik mitigasi ralat yang menghilangkan kesan bunyi hingar yang tidak diketahui semasa pelaksanaan circuit yang boleh
diskalakan dengan cara yang diketahui. Ia mengandaikan nilai jangkaan berskala dengan bunyi hingar oleh fungsi yang diketahui yang ditunjukkan di sini di mana
WEBVTT
parameter lambda menentukan kekuatan bunyi hingar dan boleh diperkuatkan. Kita boleh laksanakan ZNE dengan langkah-langkah berikut.
Pertama, perkuatkan bunyi hingar circuit untuk beberapa faktor bunyi hingar. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, dan seterusnya. Jalankan setiap circuit yang diperkuat bunyi hingar untuk mengukur
nilai jangkaan a lambda 1, a lambda 2, dan seterusnya. Dan kemudian ekstrapolasi semula ke had bunyi hingar sifar,
nilai jangkaan a sifar.
Cabaran utama dalam melaksanakan ZNE dengan berjaya adalah mempunyai model yang tepat untuk bunyi hingar dalam nilai jangkaan
dan untuk memperkuatkan bunyi hingar dengan cara yang diketahui.
Ada tiga cara biasa amplifikasi ralat dilaksanakan untuk ZNE: skalakan tempoh denyutan melalui penentukuran,
ulang gate dalam kitaran identiti, dan tambah bunyi hingar melalui pensampelan saluran Pauli.
Kita panggil yang terakhir PEA. Probabilistic error amplification adalah pilihan terbaik di sini kerana regangan denyutan sangat
mahal dari segi pengiraan. Pelipatan gate kekurangan jaminan teori dalam memelihara bias bunyi hingar. Tapi PEA boleh
diterapkan kepada mana-mana circuit yang boleh dijalankan dengan faktor bunyi hingar natif tetapi memerlukan mempelajari model bunyi hingar. PEA mengandaikan
model bunyi hingar berasaskan lapisan yang sama seperti probabilistic error cancellation.
Namun, ia mengelakkan overhead pensampelan yang berskala secara eksponen dengan bunyi hingar circuit. Untuk mempelajari model bunyi hingar,
kita perlu terlebih dahulu kenal pasti lapisan unik operasi qubit dua dalam circuit.
Untuk setiap lapisan, lakukan Pauli twirl pada gate qubit dua untuk memastikan bunyi hingar diterangkan dengan baik oleh model bunyi hingar redaman.
ulang pasangan identiti lapisan pada kedalaman yang berbeza-beza dan akhirnya padankan kesetiaan atau ralat untuk setiap saluran bunyi hingar. Dan
tentu saja, walaupun saya cadangkan memahami kaedah ini sejauh mana, melakukannya secara manual dalam Qiskit adalah
jauh lebih mudah seperti yang ditunjukkan dalam tutorial. Sekarang, akhirnya, jom tengok data yang diplot. Garis
kelabu berputus-putus menunjukkan hasil tepat yang diperoleh dengan kaedah klasikal anggaran dengan ralat anggaran
menumpu ke ambang yang rendah. Seperti yang korang boleh nampak, data mentah untuk faktor bunyi hingar berbeza yang kita pilih pada
permulaan adalah agak jauh daripada garis berputus-putus ini. Garisan biru pepejal menunjukkan data yang mengambil kira pemprosesan ZNE
kita. Dan korang boleh cakap terus ia jauh lebih dekat dengan keputusan yang tepat.
Ringkasnya, nilai berbunyi menunjukkan sisihan tinggi daripada nilai tepat. Nilai
yang dikurangkan adalah hampir kepada nilai tepat, menunjukkan utiliti teknik mitigasi berasaskan PEA.
Dan itu pada asasnya menutup episod ini. Untuk merumuskan secara ringkas apa yang kita telah pelajari, simulasi quantum adalah salah satu
kawasan aplikasi yang paling menjanjikan dalam jangka masa pendek hingga sederhana.
Ia mempunyai aplikasi yang luas daripada farmaseutikal kepada fizik tenaga tinggi,
sains bahan dan banyak lagi. Kertas utiliti dari IBM yang diterbitkan pada tahun 2023 menunjukkan
jalan ke arah mampu menggunakan komputer quantum untuk penemuan saintifik. Dan kita telah lalui
tutorial berkaitan yang mengiringi kertas tersebut dengan mendalam. Langkah-langkah untuk menyelesaikan masalah simulasi dari mula
hingga akhir adalah agak mudah, terutamanya setelah korang dah biasa dengannya. Dan harapan saya adalah korang
boleh mulai sekarang menggunakan video ini dan tutorial sebagai panduan untuk lebih banyak masalah simulasi pada masa hadapan.
Terima kasih kerana menonton dan jumpa korang kali berikutnya dalam Quantum Computing dalam Praktik.